back in back in the podcast
room hey
guys welcome back to the podcast why did
you stop I was getting down to that
because every time I sing Back In Black
I think of that car commercial now think
it's that's their uh I don't that's
their goal yeah welcome to the Jen and
Jillian
podcast today is brought to you all yeah
today's brought to you by my Superman
bathroom oh yeah you guys don't get to
see it's under it wow that was
inappropriate Julian it was
inappropriate too [__] far dude too
far yeah it's making a lot of noise yeah
the the mics are being pretty annoyed
right now sorry um sorry mics there we
go is it
good there we
go and we're back a
microphone I'm a
mic Jenna stole my glasses yeah I stole
I stole stole stole your glasses well I
really like those glasses because I've
never worn glasses and I kind of like
the way it looks except for the fact
that there's no lenses in them so I look
like an idiot grass is always greener on
the other side no I don't wish I had
glasses I got glass when I was in like
fourth grade and I was like I can't see
the board and my friend was like here
try in my glasses and I did and I was
like wait a second yeah this is magical
yeah I never went through that my vision
is perfect [__] you I'm not trying to be
mean it just is never had braces doesn't
need glasses you're just like human
2.0 well I would apologize for it but
I'm not sorry for it I have terrible
eyesight and I had braces for four years
well I didn't have I never had braces my
brother and sister both had [__] up
teeth they had braces had retainers I
had a perfect set of teeth until I got
thrown off a boat and then I had to get
a retainer did I tell that story on the
podcast I I don't know I didn't know
that you had a retainer well I was I I
was given a r seems like an odd
diagnosis was for getting thrown off a
boat well I can tell you the whole story
it make more sense all right tell us all
right I'll tell you uh so we're on a
we're on a boat my stepdad had a boat
when we were kids you on a boat you on a
boat I set you up for that one
okay we would go on uh the lake and we
would wakeboard we would do dut runs and
all sorts of fun stuff and for a kid
it's like the best thing ever so we're
you know middle school and uh me my step
brother and my stepdad went on on a
donut run which is basically when you go
really fast and then you turn are you
mocking me I just making a face oh
anyway I saw that someone took an
Instagram screenshot of like me talking
on the podcast and her just like in the
back I was being such a little dick yeah
when bae makes fun of you behind your
back um anyway we're doing a dut run so
basically you go pretty fast and then
you just crank the wheel to one side and
you cause a real big wake and you have
to hold on tight it's it's very intense
but it's it's like a it's a rush you
know if you like that stuff and anyway
we're on a dut run we did a couple
donuts and it was fun and between one of
the donuts we were just like kind of
just chilling we were just like sitting
around in the water kind of moving
around with the wake and I move out to
the front of the boat where there's not
anything to hold on to there's seats in
the back but the front is just like this
flat area where you can stand or do
whatever but when the boat's still
anyway so I'm on my knees kind of
looking around like just completely
unaware of everything and we start to go
like pretty you know decently fast like
20 30 m hour which is fast on a lake but
I was like you know I'm up here we're
not obviously we're not not going to do
any more Donuts but no uh my stepdad had
other plans I love him so much he's
awesome but he was he was just being a
little [__] and he was like you know
what I'm going to do a donut thank you
Dr hack for that one and he um flipped
it and he did the he did the hard wheel
turn and I go flying off the boat and I
don't just like fly off I like go this
way and I hit my face on the side of the
boat and then I flip into the water and
I was wearing a life vest so I I think I
sort of like lost Consciousness maybe
for a beat or two but I remember like
kind of just coming to in the water
floating there and I look up I'm like
where am I I see Josh my step brother
and and Ted laughing at me I'm like did
they think I jumped or what happened um
but I was bleeding out of my mouth and
so what happened was the side of the
boat which is like hard hard hard
plastic I think it's plastic something
whatever boats are made out of really
hard it cut through my lip but it like
pushed through the lip there was like a
little hole and then push my FR tooth
back
e you heard this
story I forgot that was part of it
anyway push this front tooth back like
so it was significantly further back
than this one so I had to get stitches
for my lip uh and then and then they
gave me a retainer and was like you have
to wear this every day for like two
years or else your tooth is just never
going to be level with the other tooth
and of course I haven't worn it so it's
not level but that's my story sorry to
gross you out I get it it I first of all
we also grew up near a lake or around a
lake my father would [__] kill
anybody that did not take water sports
seriously he would slap anybody that did
a donut ever like we weren't we were not
even allowed to go down to the bank of
the water unless my dad was with us like
he took that stuff so seriously and I
still broke my nose well that's where
that got him I know like everybody
[__] gets hurt near water sometimes
just dangerous as [__] I was the only I
was the only real C why is there flying
here I was the only real casualty on the
lake no one else ever really got hurt
you know you you do wakeboarding you do
jumps you like you know you get roughed
up but you don't get hurt like that was
like the only time someone got hurt hurt
we had to leave uh I don't know about
somebody got hurt sounds like somebody
hurt you yeah no it was a bad move by
doing that donut yeah no good don't play
on the water like that it's scary aer's
kid died like a jet ski accident yeah
okay jet skis are a different Beast I'm
not cool with those things though I mean
I've been on them and like I've never
there have been accidents that just like
make me never want to go on a jet ski
ever yeah I don't I don't really
especially when you're not driving it
that's horrifying extreme water sports
just not my thing I like canoeing and
kaying roow booting we didn't even have
a motorboat growing up or access to one
you well you can't do donuts so what is
your daddy being mad about we took the
[__] rowboat out to the middle of the
lake went F we can swim that's about it
other than that get out of the [__]
water before you hurt yourself yeah know
things can go anyway we didn't mean to
make this a waterport podcast but uh
yeah that's why I had to wear a retainer
and didn't and you didn't no you should
have seen my brother's teeth though my
brother's teeth growing up were like
horrible he had to braces for years my
sister like years braces and I was just
like nope I don't need it I was just the
me and my brother had awful teeth I was
a black sheep I am the black sheep yeah
but we like okay coming from a different
perspective I had braces for 4 years so
the day I got my retainer I could not
wait to wear that thing I was like sure
I'll wear it all day every day at least
it's a retainer at least it's not braces
at least I can feel my [__] face oh
yeah so I wore it for a long time until
I was like 25 I think I wore my retainer
and you're supposed to wear it for the
rest of your life in theory but then my
roommate's dog ate it no but that was
when I was like 20 so I had to get
another one but that one never worked as
well it was the first
and it like wasn't right so then I
slowly kind of stopped wearing it up
until now yeah you get lazy plus you
lose it no it wasn't a sense of laziness
it it like didn't move my teeth anymore
the way that I like it just like fit in
perfectly it didn't do anything anymore
right and he was like this is how you
adjust it so I like cranked the [__] out
of it because when I got my braces off
they my bite was really great like I had
braces for four [__] years like we
did the whole N9 yards yeah that's what
my brother and sister did like years of
it right yeah so ever since I didn't
have my first one I had that stupid
second one I would crank the [__] out of
it try to make it as small as possible
and jam it up in my mouth and then you'd
wake up and your teeth would hurt right
I mean a little bit but it just never
went back to the way that it was so I
got really sad I mean they're straight
my bite's not perfect anymore but let me
see oh thanks yeah know they look good
they were they were not right before no
yeah and like I I don't know I had a
giant Gap in between my two front teeth
when I was
little yeah because I really want to get
it fixed either because I thought it was
Madonna I was like but Mom I don't want
to get it fixed like Madonna has it okay
it's really cute but um I also had this
thing I don't know what it's called but
uh it's when your gum grows too long in
between your teeth yeah I don't know
what that's called I don't know either
but I just remember when I was around 6
years old I had to have it cut off wow
that is horrible and have little
stitches in there Jesus isn't that scary
You' have gone through it man you had
some [__] happen that's why when I went
I recently got my wisdom teeth out like
in the fall right and uh I was sort of
like yes I don't really want to get my
wisdom teeth I've been putting it off
since forever but like I don't know
having it done really doesn't scare me
too much at this point cuz I've had
every [__] tooth in my mouth pull out
at some point for
real like I used to go to the
orthodontist like all the time they
loved me there so I just sit there and
like yeah do what the [__] you want man
I don't care do I get a prize at the end
I'm used to that I would I would have to
go with my my brother and sister all the
time they were always there yeah always
they just never had anything wrong yeah
crazy teeth right it's really although
now like being an adult it's kind of
hard to like take care of your teeth as
much as you want to like who in the [__]
flosses like two times a day not me I
can floss once a day for like a month
and then I get tired and like pick it up
the next month yeah and then there's
like a Saturday when you don't do it and
then you're kind of like [__] and
you're like I should floss my teeth and
you're like yeah but you know what I
want to do is not floss my teth yeah not
floss
but I just went to the dentist recently
and there she was like sticking a little
hook in my gum and like telling me my
gum health and I was like lady oh my God
dentist in a nutshell they stab your gum
and then criticize your teeth CLE
cleanliness habits I was like oh [__]
God okay I guess yeah I'll [__] why
is your gum bleeding when I stab it with
this mini knife you have horrible gums
oh I know [__] I still need it I did so
why I got my wisdom teeth out I went to
the dentist
and he you know he I hadn't been in a
really long time just because I didn't
really [__] first of all I couldn't
afford it for a long time and then like
I totally could and just didn't cuz I a
piece of [__] and uh so one of my teeth
like started to bother me and i' never
had a cavity ever so I went in and got
like an evaluation order and he was like
yeah we should F this one cavity and
then you got to get your [__] wisdom
teeth out [__] and I'm like damn it I
knew you were going to say that and then
he sort of like laid out this plan for
me he was like we the the teeth next to
my front teeth are actually my canines
because my family my mom my brother and
I were all born without like the left or
the right one okay so when the baby the
baby tooth never comes out there's no
adult tooth above it it's just genetic
but the other one does yeah so you
basically had like one weird little baby
tooth next to your two front teeth and
then all the rest of your teeth are
adult teeth so they pulled out the adult
one and two of my baby MERS because I
was born without my your MERS or
something like that I'm missing like so
many teeth jeez you're like marbles yeah
so then they moved all the rest of them
forward and so the teeth next to my
front teeth are actually my canines that
they shav down a little bit and then
added a little bit of a fake tooth to
the inside of it to not make it sh shade
can9 to make them squared off like the
other ones that makes sense but the last
time I had the like fake tooth like done
I was like 16 or 14 or something like
ago so it was like literally over a
decade so obviously they like a little
bit miscolored or whatever but so the
guy was like all right yeah we'll fill
your cavity we'll take your wisdom teeth
we'll do this this and this and then you
know we'll fix that part of your teeth
so that they they look like the rest of
your teeth and I was like super man that
sounds great and so then I did all the
hard workare and then I didn't [__] I
just haven't gone back this is [__]
Santa Monica now it's was like 45
minutes away yeah well you got them
moved what you got them whitened [__]
did we talk about that on the podcast I
don't think we've talked about when you
got your teeth maybe we have oh well we
did a podcast like right after you got
your wisdom teeth out which I think we
never talked about the whitening but
that was she I've I've never seen you in
pain like that I've like you've
experienced pain I've seen you like like
when you when we were drunk that one
night and you like fell and you broke
your toe like you broke no not toe toes
I broke both of my toes both my big toes
yeah she woke up she was like ah my toe
hurts whatever I can't bend them anymore
I mean you never iced it you never saw a
doctor so it's not help it's didn't heal
right and that's not that's not not your
fault I could tell they were broken
though cuz they hurt for like six weeks
and they were black whatever what it was
some serious [__] that happened to your
toes and you were just like yeah you
know it hurts a little bit when I squat
when I work out but but I'm fine no the
teeth wiening she was crying like you
were crying crying you were like
miserable nothing could cheer you up
like and and it was like residual like
it didn't just happen and hurt it was
like hurting all day and then you went
to sleep and it hurt the next day and I
was like what the [__] I know and the
woman was really sort of rude to me
about it because I think that it's a
pretty fair assumption that people have
different levels of sensitivity to their
teeth yeah so she was sort of treating
me like oh you know I think I did the
the whitening thing four times or three
times like you sit under they put the
gel on they you sit under the light and
you do it you repeat it like three or
four times and she was like oh did you
want to do another one and at this point
I'm like it hurts so [__] bad it's
like zinging in through your nerv it
goes into your body and she was like oh
did you want to keep going and I'm just
like no no I need to [__] I want to
leave like I'm totally [__] good like
leave me alone and she would not [__]
leave me alone about it she's like oh
okay it's it's good they look great I'm
like yeah yeah can I [__] can I go
home like I'm in so much [__] pain
and then I cried after I left which was
a combination of a lot of things lot of
things yeah but I was I like it was one
of them being that lady so uncomfortable
and so awful
yeah unfortunately that's that's one of
the problems you face quite a lot when
you're nice and you're not like a
confrontational person people just take
kind of what you say and just disregard
it which is really frustrating
especially for like for me to see if I
were there I would have like lost it I
know but I just think that it's so
insulting for you're doing something
that directly like affects how sensitive
your teeth are so they're very
nonchalant about so someone that has
really sensitive teeth don't tell them
to keep white them they're already in a
lot of pain which I [__] was like I
just don't understand how coming from
someone that works at a dentist office
she didn't like even ask me sort of what
my pain level was you know what I mean
no that's insane to me yeah I was sort
of angry anyways enough about teeth yeah
well you have good teeth now I think
your teeth are good your teeth are good
I just need to fix the fake part cuz
it's I like those white strips those
don't hurt although after I got the
originally after I got my braces off we
put the little fake part in there yeah I
was flossing it one time and the whole
thing just came oh my God it looked
hysterical it looked it looked so funny
and I was sort of like I had to go about
the rest of the next couple days just
with it off like I looked like Jim car
and Dumb and Dumber oh my God you know
what I mean yeah [__] yeah so there was
that my dad once chipped his tooth on a
UFO you know those like ice cream
sandwiches the really [__] hard
chocolate yeah it was uh we were at the
park we went to the ice cream truck he
ate it chipped his [__] tooth and and
for like a week he had like half a tooth
there he looked like Jim Carrey and dum
and it was like weird as [__] but yeah F
crazy it's crazy how teeth are man
[__] teeth [__] teeth anyways we
wanted to talk about enough shut up
about the teeth all right the other
thing that we wanted to talk about
though was that so we went shopping for
a little bit today yeah we needed to get
um a couple of outfits for things coming
up and um we just like sort of baffled
like I I feel like most people including
myself including you like doing most of
their shopping online when time allows
or when other circumstances allow and
whenever it's allow when you can like
why would I go to store and buy it when
I could just order it for sure um so I
wanted to do that but I sort of ran out
of a little bit of a time so we [__]
we just went to the mall and the people
that are working in
retail I don't know if it was in this
particular place or around this
particular place or what the [__] is
going on but these sales people were so
pushy and so ridiculously like not
picking up on social cues that I was
ready to leave uh yep yep yep yep
infuriating you could say like like you
say one thing to like it's just one
thing if they like okay I understand
that they you know they're told to be
aggressive they're told I used to work
in [__] retail so yeah so tell me
how how do they you want to [__] know
the [__] yeah why don't you tell us so I
used to work at an Express in Rochester
New York or like surrounding town for
those who don't know Express is a
relatively high-end kind of clothing
store right it's like it's not high-end
but nice at many malls yeah it's a mall
store they have men's and women's yeah
this was before there was a men's I
think okay so I worked at
Express and when I got the job I was I
think it was the summer between my
freshman and sophomore year of college
and I was already working at a day camp
and then I would occasionally you know a
couple days a week and then on the
weekends go into Express and work so I
was a part-time employee but so like
you're a poor [__] college kid you're
just trying to make as much money as you
can over the summer and I got hired and
they're like all right here read this
Handbook of everything that we expect of
you aside from training aside this is
just the [__] handbook yeah it was
like you need to be wearing heels
between 3 and 5 in for your entire shift
like you better get used to it you have
to be wearing current Express clothes on
your body at all times and you can open
up an Express credit card which she
forced everyone to do and then I went
home and my mom was livid she was like I
that's so [__] wrong she closed it
for me she was like I can't believe she
did that to you cuz she just was like
all right swipe here's your new Express
credit card swipe here's yours because
she was getting like points or our
manager was getting like points for
signing up so many new credit cards she
sort of made it seem like we had to so
then she made us at a 15% discount she
made us buy Express clothes to so I
think we all to spend around $200 or
something just to get your uniform for
work just to start working but then
knowing that you would only have a month
or two window to wear that before you
had to buy more clothes and that we were
allowed to wear clothes that were on the
sale rack but only if they were
currently on the sail rack because they
want us to be walking like models for
the clothes so if if you were wearing
sale jeans I'm not even kidding you
jeans just jeans they can only be on the
sail rack like it's as soon as the last
pair of cells you have to [__] change
yeah you are only allowed to have one
piercing in which is a problem for me
because it's not like I have you know an
extensive amount of piercings or you
know anything that was considered
alternative or anything like that you're
only allowed to wear one stud no hoops
no dangly earrings one stud in each ear
your nails had to be at a short length
and paint in a neutral color I wish I
was [__] Mak them this up you could
only be wearing like this isn't all Ral
by the way this is just one experience
but yeah but anyways you could be
wearing like a watch and like a bracelet
everything had to be like in singles
like very classy they wanted us to look
like these little [__] like steep
rare wives and like I forget the rest of
it there was some other [__]
ridiculous ass [__] if if that was bad
enough like I'm you know I just get home
from a day camp I'm covered in like dirt
and mud nope you got to shower and make
sure that your nails are not chipped and
painted a neutral [__] pale pink
before you get to express and you better
[__] take off half your jewelry you
hated working there that place is
[__] right so my feet would be
[__] killing me because I'm in heels
working in retail and I'm like what the
[__] is no other this is Rochester New
York we're not in downtown Manhattan and
this isn't a [__] Chanel
and I was so [__] angry so I sort of
thought that all retail was like that
that everybody needed to look like a
little robot there was never a [__]
shirt out of place and then beyond that
in our training we had to so somebody's
job which was when I started my job was
to just stand by the door and say hello
to every single person that came in and
then say goodbye to them on the way out
can you imagine if you have not worked
in retail how [__] boring that
gets after 6 hours or so like [__]
kill me he you don't get to do anything
else yeah that's rough I mean at least
if you're like folding clothes that's
something you can do to pass the time
yeah you can fold the clothes in the
front of the store but you can't go
anywhere else you just stand there like
when once it turns like 9:00 and there's
nobody [__] coming you just have to
stand there until your shift is over no
that's rough and your heels and want to
die yeah that's rough and then if you
graduated to like the fitting room so it
was like front of the store fitting room
cash register this is the path you
wanted to go yeah because if you were at
the cash register you can at least like
lean on it and like chat to your
girlfriend and [__] hang out so for
the fitting room if you worked the
fitting rooms it was your job to
literally go ask what they're wearing
you you know walk around the [__]
store like you're basically a sales
assistant at that point you're you're
pushing stuff on the floor if you sold a
certain number of pair of jeans of
[__] week or however long they deemed
it you would get like Regional points
but it would go towards our store you
know what I mean like oh you're the top
sales in the it's not yeah it's not
doing you any [__] good you know what
I mean and we'd have [__] staff
meetings one time I wor jeans like
ripped jeans to a staff meeting and I
got reamed for it she was like you need
to show up it was 11 o00 at night at the
mall but anyways so it was our job when
we were doing sales to find out whatever
they were wearing try and basically
become their best [__] friend they
like wanted you to get customers to
depend on you to like think that you
know everything about everything and to
be your best friend like they they want
you to make small talk and like what
Bond so the customer wants to want more
and then this was the the part that I
had the hardest with so after they pick
out their outfit we had to go on our own
and pick out something that we thought
would go with whatever they picked and
I've seen that when we go shopping and
throw it over the door do you know how
awful I
it's so invasive it's terrible not to
mention if someone had just picked out a
couple of pairs of jeans to try on I
don't know what size top they are I
would have to go and like guess and like
give them a medium or something and then
I'd be like you have to follow up be
like how's everything working out for
you first of all you knock how's
everything working out for you while
they're in there and then after that you
have to be like oh did you love that top
that I gave you and half the time oh my
God what are they thinking is going to
happen they they it pushes sales they
had some [__] statistic that just
throwing an item over the door increased
sales by like 75% oh my God okay I'm
going to say something now hold on do
you know how many times though they were
like yeah I mean I really didn't want
that shirt first of all and second of
all it's not my size okay it's so
embarrassing and humiliating and I got
this is how I got put in the back I had
a short s in the cash register I made it
for like a couple of days and then I was
not throwing clothes over to customers I
was trying to get away with not because
it made me so uncomfortable that they
put me in the back room to steam clothes
and like do inventory good probably the
best job you can get I was so happy I
can't even tell you but I needed that
job yeah no I get I just think I think
it's so like when there's when there's
like a company that you know has all
corporate rules or whatever and there's
you know people who are doing research
on if you do this you'll sell one more
article of clothing a day and like I
think it's so infuriating and like
disgusting of companies to look at those
statistics and say [__] how the customer
feels [__] being a normal person like
ignoring all of what makes shopping
enjoyable just to make an extra couple
of [__] dollars right like it just it
boils my blood because like you are then
becoming just a profit robot machine
you're not caring whatsoever about
customer service you're not caring about
the experience that the customer is
having you're not caring about how
comfortable they are you're just
throwing your you're you're shoving your
way of doing things down their throats
just so you can make a dollar and it's
disgusting I hate it I agree I hate
hearing about that I agree because in we
were never really allowed to give our
opinion the only like in terms of
freedom for problem solving that we were
given is if someone doesn't like
something hurry up and [__] find
something that they do like do you know
what I mean so if someone put on a pair
of jeans and we all know how difficult
it is to find a pair of jeans that fit
anybody it's just Universal for everyone
frustrating so like obviously not all
these genes are going to make [__]
people happy so I would have a girl that
would come out and she would be like I
don't know I don't really like these
like how do you think they look I'm not
allowed to be like they're okay but you
know maybe if you went to [__] H&M
they might have something that was
shorter or because that's being a real
human being why would you be allowed to
I'm not allowed to say that I'm only
allowed to be like oh my God they look
so great on you as soon as people come
out we have to compliment them but the
most infuriating part was so I basically
was in this insanely strict Express and
then I moved sounds like I moved to
Boston and I I I refused to go into the
store for several years but my friend
Jackie loved ex no I get your
reservations though so I went in there
and there's [__] clothes everywhere
girls are just wearing their SU sneakers
and I'm just like are you [__]
kidding me like that place was my hell I
was so miserable and everyone's just so
like chill no one even said hello to
us threw anything over the door how long
after you working there did you go to
the other Express I want to say it took
me a good two years my guess is that
someone [__] stood up to their
corporate [__] and said this is not
allowed we're going to change that's my
guess I don't think it was I don't think
it was the different stores policy I
think someone finally [__] made
change by the time you went back do you
know how hard it was for me to make
money since we could only wear it sounds
it sounds like [__] concentration
camp it sounds horrible I know well you
know that that might be exaggeration you
know every month at least 200 of your
dollars are just coming right out of
your paycheck and it's such a like
that's a pyramid scheme right there it's
[__] stupid like you can never get
anywhere unless you get promoted and
even you're becoming a slave almost like
you're you're owing debt oh I forgot to
tell you the worst part so we had
earpieces is in the entire time and if
ever you're with a customer your manager
or my maybe my manager was just insane
but she would just like tell you to give
her things and like do things and say
things to your customer and like you're
kind of put on the spot cuz they can see
and hear you so you kind of have to do
it [__] that that is such [__] yeah
I felt it was like you must have felt so
good when you stopped working there
right and when people ask me about go-o
dancing and bartending like yeah of
course there's Parts about jobs every
job that you don't like yes but it felt
so freeing to not have to have people
micromanage you or God those rules man
those rules just make everyone miserable
everyone customers the employees
everyone it makes me miserable hearing
about it thank you express I'm never
shopping at your store I mean they're
not it's not like they're flourishing
right now because I feel like Forever 21
H&M Zara
yeah no it's it's expresses a little bit
on the downswing I think because the
people that work cuz they're not [__]
Progressive right I've never had a
problem at a Forever 21 or an H&M Top
Shop Zara any of those places with pushy
customer service because I think that
they figured out that that's not what is
selling clothes having good clothes is
what's selling
clothes seriously and having nice like
nice people like how how hard is it to
just like teach your employees that if
you're genuinely nice that alone is
going to make people want to come back
you know if if they enjoy your product
like it's very very simple I know people
are always trying to find a fast way to
success like what's the best way we can
maximize profits by doing this and that
no maybe just be nice maybe just have a
good product help people be an attendant
you would want to help you when you go
shopping and and then you [__] make
everyone happy there's no [__] it's
not there's no balance because there's
plenty of places where you can like if
from from my experience if you go into a
Forever 21 and you did need help it
might take a couple of [__] minutes
to find somebody to get off their cell
phone to come and [__] help you but
for you know the 99% of the time that
you're shopping there and want to be
left alone you will be left alone which
is fantastic you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah um but on the other hand of
things in a place like a like a BCBG or
a [__] Michael Kors I cannot me
personally I don't know about other
people I'm sure people that like look
rich and are [__] like done to the
nine get helped immediately but it's
very hard for me to get service in a
nice store like I used to walk
everywhere with my turtle backpack can I
tell you how difficult it was for me to
go and try on like a nice pair of shoes
it's profiling that's how it works it's
horrible I couldn't I all my college and
high school years I couldn't walk into a
7-Eleven without the guy looking at me
like I was going to go steal some chips
I'm serious it's just age profiling yeah
that's that's how it was that kid's
going to go [__] steal some Snickers
and and as as much as I hate it you know
what he probably has a lot of [__]
kid kids steal [__] so no no no yeah
well yeah let's not get into that issue
because profiling aside is bad yeah it's
none of it's good but it is it's sort of
a hit or miss like you're either getting
no service in a retail store or way too
much service and that's a great Point
there's never like a nice easy medium of
someone saying hey I I'll be over here
and then actually being over there like
tonight we went shopping and this this
guy was like and and it was like a chick
store like this is not a [__] store I
don't know why he's working there
American Apparel or Lululemon this is
Lululemon Lululemon so Lululemon he was
working at they spell [__]
leggings [__] leggings he's
there to watch girls try on leggings
whatever and we're we we walk together
he's like hey guys how you doing and I'm
like we're like good thanks and he's
like can I help you with anything and
I'm like uh you know like no we're just
looking let you know and he's like all
right I'll be over here I was like okay
we'll let you know if we need help and
then 30 seconds later he like sees us
talking about some leggings and he comes
and give us like a speech about what
leggings are good for what and why why
why you can sweat in these leggings and
not laugh that's dude that's creepy and
weird and also annoying that we already
told you to go away and you're coming
back with that how it works I already
have some do you think she's never worn
leggings it's because it's because I was
wearing my jeans today oh my God that's
why it happened isn't it I mean I I can
if that happened while I was there what
would have [__] happened if you
walked in there alone he would have just
bothered you the whole time espe a cuz
you're a girl and B cuz you're nice
H do you want me to put them on for you
oh God let me pull them up for you and
then pull them down for you and then the
lady at the front the register was like
so nice and normal I was like what what
super sweet super sweet like how's how's
your going I'm like remember remember
the progression I told you yeah but
that's those people need to be working
in two separate stores he was no they if
you're good at sales on the floor you
move to the register so she was
obviously that good and helpful and
sweet and nice saying is that
[__] should not have been hired
at that store because at that store they
clearly know what good customer service
is yeah but maybe they need a man to be
selling all that mulu man [__] no no no
no they don't they absolutely don't I
imagine that a man going into a
Lululemon store would not be upset if it
was a beautiful woman helping them that
guy was not beautiful he was weird oh
yeah he just wasn't right for any job
really he should just be like a direct
TV like on the phone that's when you
call he talks yeah yeah he had the right
level of cre
oh man Jesus and then and then tonight
we were shopping at the at the American
Apparel register he's like undoing the
security things and like [__]
standing there for 10 minutes like not
even no exaggeration 10 minutes first of
all he grabs the wrong stack of clothes
he Rings up all those clothes and we're
like what is this we didn't even like
those aren't ours and he's like oh sorry
sorry about it um what's a name for your
receipt yeah he asked me for my name for
the receipt and I was like that doesn't
even make any [__] sense
that's not how receipts work your
receipt is an itemized list of what we
just bought why do you need a name your
[__] your email address your phone
number we walked into that store you got
address and they were like okay uh
what's your phone number like right off
the bat nothing first time every time
someone asked me that and Jen's like you
know what I'm going to opt out of that
you can just charge me and I'll pay for
it and I'm like do you just do you just
ask people their phone number like first
thing that's insane yes because they
want your [__] address they want your
phone number they want your email
address because they want to bombard do
with [__] and you we're talking about
Apple pay no exactly and Apple pay is
trying to bypass all this whatever we we
don't have to get into that but I mean
we've talked a lot about how cash is
becoming obsolete and kind of stupid but
to its defense and my buddy Mark he's
very oldfashioned that way he carries
around cash he pays for things in cash
he keeps receipts stuff like that and
you can you know say it's much more
convenient for a credit card but you
know as much as that's annoying he'll go
into a store like that they'll be like
what's your phone number what's your
email and be like Oh I got cash sorry
I'm just going to pay for this and then
leave they don't give you know you mean
yeah we don't they don't get to know
they don't get to know it's this and
that like that's it it's like that Mitch
Hedberg thing when he's like well I
wanted to buy some gum I can't remember
ever needing a situation to prove that I
bought this gum remember like why would
I want a receipt for it's just insane
it's getting out of hand really cuz the
stores I feel like are just getting more
and more desperate to keep you coming
physically into stores instead of online
so they're like What's your phone number
what's your email right but that
unfortunately it's sort of a little bit
of an old construct that we don't really
need to hold on to but a lot of jobs are
are there
so just like I I feel bad for people too
though that work in real retail because
they have worked in retail and I know
that it's not them personally although
that creepy guy was creepy because
that's him personally but for most
people when they ask you for stuff like
that that girl was super sweet when I
said I'm sorry is it okay if I don't
give it to you and she said she was she
was nice and you know she has to ask
that that's the problem like she
probably does not she does not want to
be asking that question but she is job
[__] I high-fived myself so hard for
doing just the just the right amount of
shitty to get put in in the that's
that's the calculated demotion that's
beautiful work right there so happy no
that's
good man moral of the story just if you
can just shop online I know right it's
so funny like uh I remember one of my
comments of one of my Vlogs where we
were going physically somewhere to shop
and they were like oh that's cute you
don't buy everything on Amazon and I'm
like as much as you're roasting me right
now you have a point like you can really
do everything from your computer get
everything you need I know it is I have
had a little bit of a frustrating time
in the past buying clothes online like
if you especially for me when I do some
events like you kind of got to make sure
that you're covered everywhere like
you're meeting mostly young young
teenagers you don't want like bending
over at a table it can only be so short
and I know that there's plenty of
YouTubers that have no problem with that
but I feel inappropriate like I try I
try and keep keep the girl rolls away
and keep it so you're not going to see
my [__] butt all day um so a lot of
times I end up being like relatively
closed that it is hard to find like I
have like big [__] strong man Chick
arms and like they're not man a giant
chick donk so like sometimes sometimes
it's hard to just order something online
and then have that be a thing that works
out so chick sometimes I have to go into
a store and like try it on no absolutely
and that's that's true even for me you
come up fast too like a lot of these
things [__] come up fast and then you
don't have time to get shipping have
time
yeah but [__] man if I could just have a
sign on my face that says don't [__]
talk to me that'd be fantastic you know
we should try that sometimes just go to
the mall with a sign around your neck
[__] what about going to the mall
with your iPod headphones in and just
pretend you can't hear anyone like
blasting music like I can't hear you I
something like way more in your face
than that just walk in with the middle
finger be Nick Diaz just that's how Nick
Diaz shops he walk you can't shop cuz
you need your hands no because you need
your hands to shop that's true what
about one middle finger that used his
hand a sign around my neck that says
don't [__] talk to me I would love to
see who has the balls just say anything
to me when what if what if we made that
a
video yeah [__] horrible we should go
can't film people without their
permission well we should blur
everyone's faces [__]
them they're just trying to steal our
money
trying to throw [__] into my dressing
room anyway excuse me sir you can't film
in here yeah yeah you're going to be
blurred out anyway so [__]
you I don't think how it work excuse me
you can't film in here H shut the [__]
up I have a business call I have a
business call where's the wine
list I was wondering if I could see the
wine list uh sir I'm going to have to
ask you leave can I have the wine list
at least before I go I think we would
all like to have the wine list before we
leave there isn't a wine list this is an
ex
okay anyways I don't think I knew when I
was like 19 years old that retail is not
for me nor really is sales good for you
for you know because sales through that
Andes having the patience sales is
really really hard and it sort of takes
the right type of person to be good at
it absolutely absolutely because I'm I'm
just not in the business of making money
off of someone without you know feeling
I I just don't want to tell someone to
buy something that I don't think that
they should [__] buy you're right and
that's why people who are good in
business and sales like that and
marketing or whatever are good because
they're not good people because they do
what works that's not true well no I'm
not saying in in a general sweeping
statement I'm seeing like you know
people who are more you know kind of
centered towards you know I don't know
uh methods of doing things to make more
things happen like just there's very
like I guess mathematically minded or
certain ways of how demographics react
aren't you know are going to be good at
like that kind of thing because they
have less worry about you know social
interaction they have less worry about
how the feeling is I think that people
that are behind that I think the people
that are good at sales are good at
seeing the positive in things they're
offering something that helps people or
that people like or that makes them
happy they think that they're bringing
it to those people and they're doing a
good job of being informative and
helpful and all that I think that sales
people can be wonderful people and can
do it in a way that's not offensive and
invasive but I think that there are some
[__] used car salesmen that would
love to just focus on numbers and cash
and [__] everybody well that's the only
reason Express that's the only reason
Express had any sort of rules like they
did when you work there because of those
people yeah they just want money and
dollars yeah they're maximizing profits
they don't give a [__] what else happens
I I think that there is a balance
between making sales and helping people
and being money hungry there exists a
balance I just don't know
where come on
what nothing ever no I just I what do
you mean I just don't know where like I
don't I can't name a store at the top of
my head where I know they're 100% going
to be nice to me and also help me what
about like the Apple Store nobody in
there is walking around I'm thinking
about clothing though oh well retail
clothing that's you know what you what
you think of any store that you go into
Best Buy sucks they have the worst
customer service that's a retail St yeah
I know except for that one guy Max at
Best Buy insance El he hooked me up cool
shout out he's the man no cuz like cuz
you go into a store like that and no one
can help you and then one person's like
oh sure yeah of course I can do that for
you I have a wonderful time at Guitar
Center we've been there a couple times
right that's where you got your ukulele
mhm
yeah all right I guess I was thinking
mostly of clothing stores which I still
can't I mean H&M people are pretty nice
um I don't know I just I get overwhelmed
and I
think what I'm just I think Victoria
Secret does a really nice job of being
respectful because they're selling
something that still for some reason is
a little bit taboo do you know what I
mean yeah so they're they're very
respectful of people's privacy when
you're looking for underwear and bras
and when they say I'll be over here if
you need help they mean it and they
don't try and [__] follow you at
least in my experience well like that
other store across from uh you know it
was like the last time we went to the
mall where you were trying on a bunch of
stuff and that older lady was helping
you oh my God and she kept coming into
the dressing room when I was
naked you asked me why I wanted whatever
yeah Julian had had it that day I was
looking for a dress like a a semiformal
dress and uh it was her store like I
think they were her designs or something
like that and or she was just a shitty
human being there's always that possib
that's happened to me twice there was
one in Westwood and then there was one
here where it's the woman who like owns
the store and and they're her [__]
designs and not these aren't like
expensive ass fancy places they're just
like people that happen to rent a little
space in the mall and she both of them
kept coming in that that one girl was
saying like oh your body is so perfect
for this as she like felt me up and down
and I was like
um I got to
go getting very uncomfortable but the
the older blonde lady that reminded me
of Ursula the sea witch yeah she was
rough she made me mad just blatantly
kept coming in while I was in my
underwear and or just ass naked and I
felt like I was at the YMCA with my mom
yep [__] that if if we ever go shopping
and I get mad 99% of the time it's about
people working and nothing else not
about how I'm hungry or not being enough
Chipotle that's the 1% that happened
today and we broke down and ate Chipotle
oh
Chipotle but anyway it's a good venting
session I think yeah because it's just
really [__] hard to for clothes
without somebody breathing down your
neck and or feeling like hello can
anyone [__] help me but what's your
phone number thing is just like out of
this world to me yeah God it's very diff
all right let's put it this way it's
very difficult to leave the mall feeling
super like you didn't get violated at
all yeah that's a good way to put it do
you remember we went I was looking for
like a handbag or something for the
award show whatever and those people in
there that one girl in the [__] store
oh my God we it got so bad with her that
every time we went there we would like
sort of peer in the window to see if
that girl was working because and we
wouldn't go there if she was there so
outrageous but they another time when we
I think we actually did successfully get
that little handbag they were like so uh
what are you doing oh where are you
going or what's it for and this and that
and they literally they got to I was
like do you want to know the day I was
born like would you like to know about
my parents like you have to be rude at a
certain point cuz they just don't get
get it I know and I'm like I can't even
look at what I'm looking at because I'm
trying to be polite and look at your
face while I'm talking to you but I'm
not here to [__] amazon.com doesn't
have commission I'm going to go there I
know thanks this is [__] even then
they take all your information dude that
girl wanted to know your workout routine
she was like no seriously what what do
you do tell me I want to do what you do
I know and I was like look the mall's
closing 20 you're trying to make money
and you're asking for a workout plan I
know but they they like don't respect
the fact that you might only have like
45 minutes to get something they
disrespect everything about you yeah
like I'm not here to [__] just have a
strolly calm nice time at the mall like
I'm kind of here to get [__] and that's
the only reason that I'm here anyway my
parents didn't drop me off at the mall
with my friends to go get slushies and
and scope out boys stupid stupid
okay anyway yeah benting good vening let
us yeah let us [__] know let us know
your experience yeah what your experien
is with retail shopping and if you do it
or not and if there's people that
[__] bother you yeah and tell your
stories I love when people like tell
stories about [__] we talk about because
there's got to be some good [__]
retail stories but we will be back next
Monday for another podcast maybe less
ranty probably less ranty maybe little
more
happy we love you guys thanks for
watching and listening go PA guys see
you next week next week next next week
next week next week oh uh oh Adele does
[Music]
it